[Music]
welcome to ask the boys the only show on
the internet where you can ask the boys
i asked a bunch of questions on my
instagram so the only way you're going
to be able to ask questions is make sure
you follow all of our instagrams and
wait for the moment when we say yo ask
us a question and today we have a huge
list from people that were in my stories
perfect thank you joe for the setup so
here we go uh the first question comes
from say
the yellow kind and the question is how
hot is anthony's sister the answer is
very very very how [ __ ] hot if she
looks anything like anthony she's very
hot very hot
i don't think i've ever met your sister
what's the next question all right let's
go the next question is
the next question is can you guys talk
about the travis scott concert on jk
news also give anthony's sister a shout
out for me [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the video went up today actually so
it went up today bring my sister into
astro world dog
i don't get it all right
um
[Music]
oh hey maybe this is for nick
the question is how do i make love to a
lesbian
who is this person this is from
constagram
it actually says that
no it literally says how do i make love
to a lesbian uh i don't know why i'm the
authority on this we're talking we're
talking about a lesbian
uh i'll say this i mean you're the
closest one that can help us out here
it's so funny when it's not about your
sister and i'm like
i thought you had a hot lesbian so this
is what anthony lee feels like
you can't answer that i don't know
i wish i knew i love our fans
i just [ __ ] love our fans
these guys don't respect your patreon
dollars apparently
i don't know you know what's cool is
that every like you know i'm always like
who watches this [ __ ]
who watches the [ __ ] we've been here for
15 years and some of these guys they've
been like on the long run dude you know
now on youtube you can see like if
you're in the account there's like a
little red dot next to their name and
you can like you could kind of put your
cruiser over and it'll tell you how many
years we got some like decade fans six
years 10 years so shout outs to you guys
[ __ ] amazing i can see you guys big
time thank you guys but you know that
they're like an extended friend that we
never met right cause they watched us
grow they understand our humor they
connect to our humor so they're gonna
get a lot of our [ __ ] jokes and then
so they come up with some funny [ __ ]
themselves some of these questions i'm
dying bro and i'm like oh we can't say
some of this [ __ ] but it's so good so
far i've said all the ones that was like
i don't know if we can say that so it's
been great
it's juicier okay next question is from
robbies.privy
he says is it better to use fingers or
mouth to make a girl all caps go crazy
both down on our pulse probably above
but
you start with a single you add the
double the combination is killer yeah i
say do you see hey you see how the
confidence is that this guy
this guy has so much sex it's crazy okay
and this is a genuine question for you
as a friend
how do you eat [ __ ] with this little
the little soul patch because the the
chicks don't always like that i don't
eat it with my chin i you know my tongue
no but i know right but but because
sometimes you get a little cross rub
it's never really been an issue that was
either spoken of or brought up to me i i
think i keep most of the
when i'm doing both
this right here stays in the lower area
this right here stays in the upper outer
clay area so it's not like it like
penetrates so deep that i'm pushing my
[ __ ] chin hairs into the vaginal
canal
[ __ ] dude
you never seen that strap-on that people
hit the chit strap
i've been getting size for one but i
can't find the one that fits me
perfectly it's not to your chin not to
your fan yeah yeah
uh i don't use fingers because my
chick's not into fingers so i only use
mouth and uh well you'll [ __ ]
stretch her [ __ ] out with those fingers
dude
yeah usually guys would use two fingers
if you use two man that [ __ ] steve has
to use his pinky that's not good yeah i
would but she wouldn't let me so anyway
she's just like he's already
yeah it gets the job done i'm telling
you i used to be a finger master i was a
figure right master because i was like
one of those people who's like virgin
told her like wait it's like wait so you
learned the the movie so i was the
fingerprint master and like why because
now i'm married and like i can't even
use all my powers
what's your rate your best quality is
the wrong move like on a scale from 100
like what would it be 100 out of 100
yeah no question see that confidence
that's scary i love it nah the way you
did it was like you were seducing all of
us the way you were talking about yeah
yeah you went i was like dude i'm
getting hot and heavy right now i still
want to know about your lesbian sister
what about her yeah how do you make her
cub how do i make my sister come is that
what they make love to a lesbian brother
dude so maybe you could talk to a
lesbian about making love maybe you
would have some insight but instead we
didn't know you just you know what i
don't ask i don't ask my sister about
her love life
but you know
what what do you want me to ask myself
[ __ ] call right now we could be like
yo how do you [ __ ] make a lesbian
come thank you
okay let's let's be let's be respectful
human beings here lesbians
straight doesn't matter
you come you come right we gotta figure
out how all of our sisters come dude you
know what the truth is
some of us know already yeah we said it
dude anthony put it out there we all
have to say it
who said what
it's not my fault if a girl can't come
wait
christ
oh my god honestly
that's actually pretty true
scientifically because they found out
that you know when when girls can't have
uh boys which was like from the medieval
times it because of the girl's fault
they found that out that's why king
harry be [ __ ] chopping off all those
holes up
this is a fact that's exactly yeah
what does the show become i'm gonna tell
you this is hot seat for joe i'm gonna
tell you something real this is
i'm trying to be serious and [ __ ] be
in touch with my side
i'm about to be really vulnerable right
now let's go laughing at me and [ __ ]
dude
right now i you know i i noticed that i
said that that you know like it's the
girl's fault if they don't come not me
you know and it's because i'm insecure
because i never made a girl come
mm-hmm so i because of sex haver like
you i need to learn can you teach me how
to make a go wait a minute
oh how the tables have turned
i tried to
god you know how many times i try to
throw [ __ ] and they won't come where you
try to yeah you throw [ __ ] and you're
like why aren't you coming stupid yes
yeah i try everything i try i try
fingering your butthole yeah i try
making out with her butt yeah everything
she won't come that's [ __ ] up dude
yeah
i'm saying i put in a lot of work here
and one like i don't want to i don't
want a pity orgasm i want a real one but
for some reason i try everything dude i
swear to god i let her lick my ass and
everything she still doesn't come you
should take her to the doctor and just
be like and like what's wrong i don't
know she won't come out
i don't know she has one of those things
wrong with her you know yeah try
everything yeah she wouldn't come when
she was licking your
[ __ ] how many guys would let the girl
do that no i feel you for sure right um
dude what else we got steve i
motorboated titties and everything still
did it we're gonna let this go for five
more minutes okay we'll circle back and
then we'll circle back here
all right here we go uh
motorboat was a for sure thing
i [ __ ] let her watch me jack off and
she still wouldn't come oh my gosh
okay next question is from jamie she
says when are you bringing ass the feels
back we did call ask the boy
this is it you're in it we just talk
about sex right now what do you want
i was vulnerable dude [ __ ] we're giving
up
giving him advice right now too
jamie don't upset him come on
this is from peter he says tacoma or
silverado
oh [ __ ] tacoma baby that's why i got one
yeah
uh how do you start your own
miguel says how do you start your own
production agency or tips on freelancing
ask this dude right here he got a studio
photo studio oh
tips on freelancing you just gotta start
doing it
that's a good tip for offer free work
are we all build a resume in some way
shape or form a freelancer yeah yeah
the best thing that's the two for life
the best ways trying to be a paid lancer
but other than that yeah
i will say though with freelancing or
when you do any like a type of
contracting job uh in your field i think
it's really really important when you're
kind of representing yourself to uh
ask the right questions to figure out
what like the kind of like for example
like rates are i remember when i was
like teaching classes and stuff like
that overseas and whatnot it would be
like weirdly taboo for people to be like
hey how much are you getting paid or how
much are you getting paid but then i
would just be that guy to like try to
figure out the right way to get the
information the second would be like oh
it's like hey do you mind letting me
know like what your rate is for this and
they would say something and immediately
i'd be like [ __ ] it i'm raising my rate
yeah so i think the freelancing gig like
oftentimes people kind of traverse
through their own respective fields or
industries and they don't necessarily
ask certain questions that can
very basically speed up your entire
progression on that
yeah you know what i do i'd be like yo
anthony what is your rate 500 bucks
hey dude i think do it for 500 i'll do
it for 450 higher
no lie absolutely no [ __ ] lie
absolutely there's a strategy and if you
could offer more value for a lower cost
that inherently makes you more about the
field i don't want to today's video is
brought to you by tushy
so you know when we went on our trip to
japan like everywhere had bidets like
public restrooms at the park had bidets
malls everywhere right and that
definitely changed our lives but during
that time
it was too expensive for me to actually
get one and i was like i don't know man
like
it's nice and all but like it felt like
a luxury yeah thank goodness we
partnered up with tushy several years
ago and they sent me one and i was able
to still get the luxuries of a bidet but
at the same time
if i were to buy it too it's super
affordable and
it wasn't like those crazy high-tech
ones where you need to plug into a wall
and you got to get like a special guy to
like set it up for you or anything it's
a super simple design you can just go
ahead and just put it together real
quick and it's not that hard to do you
don't have to have an engineer or
anything like that and it uses the water
pressure from the toilet to just make
that whole thing work so that's what i
really love about it yeah and because
it's not too expensive
if your friends come over and try it
it's easy to recommend to your friends
because everyone can afford it and um
have you ever done the butt scratch test
no what is the butt scratch so i've
never i've never done it myself but what
i hear from all my friends is if you
don't use the bidet and you wipe it with
traditional toilet paper when you
scratch your butt and you smell it
doesn't smell very good ow right no
later on if you do the test where you
use a bidet especially a tushy um
when you scratch your butt and you smell
it it's scentless because you're wow
that's taking a nice clean shower you
just spray it pat dry it and you're able
to use 80 less toilet paper and you have
a nice clean button who doesn't like
that you have very scientific friends
yeah so i'm not saying i did it but my
friends they're very scientific so if
you want a nice clean butt for you for
your girlfriend for your boyfriend your
dad your mom especially this holiday
season where people get the most played
out gifts already
give people the gift of a clean butt
okay yeah and you got and you can get a
special deal anytime you listen to us of
course so go to hellotushy.com
off the record to get 10 off plus free
shipping buy as many as you need
wonderful you could buy one for yourself
or if you're like me you have one on
every single toilet in your house buy
for your whole family hello to sheet.com
off the record for 10 off plus free
shipping uh jm pineapple says this one's
kind of deep but how do you deal with a
stressful and depressive state have a
great day
you add have a great day to anything
difficult and you're good
how do you deal with depression
stressful and depressive states oh
man i don't know how many times i could
beat my dick until i can feel better
how do how do i handle it yeah uh
i'm in touch with this one yeah i just
try to be around my friends
more are you an
extrovert i ki i'm like a mix all right
yeah you need your time yeah he's an
ambivert dude
you're just like a bird that's called
the ambivert yeah cause like you're both
i wanna be around people but some days i
just wanna go home and just like chill
not be around anybody and
i just i just try to be around friends
or like
i'm i'm kind of weird like when i'm
depressed i like to like listen to
depressing music and stuff like you kind
of i heard someone say this and it's
kind of true you kind of get like
addicted to the feeling of like
being depressed or being stressed or
having anxiety but for me like i said
mainly just like being around friends
are like doing like the stuff that i do
try to do it more so like
you know fishing you want to go fishing
dog oh i'll make you i'll give you
happiness i love fishing yeah
yeah let's go fishing
yeah jk fishing
i do i do co-sign that though uh when i
was like a little bit more down and in
the funk especially like trying to be
creative and stuff like that you get
like blocked and you feel all [ __ ]
weird about your [ __ ] being all
sensitive um one of my only things that
would help me get myself out of that
funk would to
be around my friends because in your
mentality maybe you don't have the
strength to like talk about how you're
actually a good person but you can at
least have the strength to acknowledge
that other people around you are good
yeah and if they're willing to hang out
with you then you can't be half bad you
know what i'm saying so i think
validation for yourself through
validating others is actually a really
helpful technique let you know that
you're around the right people
yeah meditation
physical movement nature stoicism
buddhism meditating stuff like
meditation i said again i'll say it
again because that's how it works
number one
breathing dude
just
focus on breath
really help me deal with um controlling
my emotions yeah
get some sunlight too hell yeah it's all
the basic stuff that you need to do
physical activity exercise making sure
you're eating somewhat healthy a little
bit of weed and stop thinking yeah
practice not thinking you got to build
momentum you got to build momentum and
start getting yeah a pattern a routine
some structure i feel like what happens
to a lot of people is that they have a
lack of structure and therefore it
causes them to kind of be in this
perpetual state of them never moving
forward in a way and i feel like that
adds to a lot of depression for a lot of
people and have a goal dude i swear to
god okay and and this is going to suck a
little bit for me personally because i
actually just hit a goal recently and it
actually happened two mornings ago where
every morning that i wake up i've talked
about how pity i am for years but every
morning when i wake up i think about the
time when i told my family to buy
the bear market for crypto when it was
on a low when it was on a low and i was
like and me and my brother were saying
if you took your stimulus check right
now and you dumped it into ethereum or
like like omg which we were in the time
like you're going to do really well and
they said i might as well check our
money into a fire right that's that's
the response they said
well they had their champagne glasses
yeah yeah and they all and they all
agreed with each other last with each
other in our family group text right and
then i i
after that i'm not kidding every morning
when i wake up i think about that i
think about that oh wait you don't
screenshot it and send it to him no no
no no no no no he's he's the pettiness
for fuel i use the predators for fuel
every morning when i wake up to show
them that i i will win and you will lose
and you will have to [ __ ] suck it oh
you're doing a big surprise cake yeah
you're not sending it every morning like
look at how much today no no i waited
waited till the milestone got hit with
me and my brother at the same time
because my brother i like i
he he started with nothing yeah right
and he took like i want to say like um i
mean he's scooping the bear low and all
that stuff and he took like about 20
grand and turned it into a huge amount
of money right that we just hit uh two
mornings ago that's awesome so we texted
our family because we talked about it
for two years we're like we're gonna
text them
and like just send them our portfolio
and say next time you want to win
you're not chucking your money into a
fire like this is how you [ __ ] win
but you have to beg
and uh
[Laughter]
we did that like two mornings ago and i
i've never felt better was it like a big
anchor just left your [ __ ] body came
10 times in a row
and i need to go to bed and it was 8 30
in the morning wow
go to bed it was beautiful it was
beautiful living through your [ __ ]
joy right now that's awesome so
beautiful in your [ __ ] all they could
do is just go congrats that's crazy wow
good job fast forward they're depressed
now yeah
how do you handle your depression pass
it off to somebody else but having that
goal
are they so prideful though to the point
where they won't want to get into it or
are they just like oh how did you do i
want to do it we'll see because it's
only been two days but i'm assuming that
eventually the reality will sit in
they'll be like yo how'd you do this
[ __ ] again i can't believe you did it
again right because i've done it before
so so that's what i'm excited about is
for them to come around and ask me that
but even if they don't i don't give a
[ __ ] because i want so
i had a goal and now that it's you know
some people are winning here because
your brother story's opposite of mine
where i came from wealth and it's now
been depleted because of crypto whereas
you know he you know it's like as long
as one of us is winning
it's okay it's okay
i'll get
there joseph by the way the next
question is how did you become such a
good actor
all right here we go here we go okay uh
what's the best piece of advice you've
ever had and who said it to you from
faded lx that's a good question oh
that's a deep one you have to think
about that
all right i i got one um i remember like
my cousin was training me like like like
[ __ ] like you know like my [ __ ]
fitness coach and [ __ ] right and then he
saw me do my bitch-ass push-ups right
because i was thinking like i want to
impress some show i could do like as
much as i can right and he was watching
me and he's like
man you're only cheating yourself well
and he walked away
and i was like
oh damn i half-assed that [ __ ] dude and
until now i'm like no one should look
over me challenging myself because i'm
just cheating me like
and i'm like i just gotta do the full
force of everything now
and then that's when i became my
obsessed self when i do things i
remember when you first said that and
then i remembered that when i was in the
gym oh really yeah because you said that
a long time ago i think like years ago
because you would half fast and you're
like yeah
okay i'm not gonna do the whole
extension or if you like have three left
you just do them all whack yeah it's
like oh well then i'm only [ __ ]
ripping myself off yeah
that's true even in bed when i'm [ __ ]
i don't know i'm still thinking yeah
yeah it's a toughy it's a tempting topic
don't eat yellow snow yeah that's a good
one
someone's advice right yeah best piece
of advice you ever had and who said it
to you
i remember who said it to me but i i do
remember hearing one time um
that like you should uh you are like who
you surround yourself with
and ever since then i just started
leaching onto as many rich people as
possible
man you in the wrong circle homie yeah
obviously that's why you always lose
[Laughter]
for me it was rick flair and he said
that's mine too
i'm sure this works you know what i mean
okay uh
is joe planning to grow his hair as long
as hannah's your girlfriend
or do a surprise haircut out of nowhere
what's the story with your hair oh i
just asked hannah to be in charge of
what i look like i was like if you want
my hair to keep growing she goes yeah
let's see how it goes i'll be like all
right you just tell me when to cut it
because it's easier when someone else is
in charge
especially because that's her background
she's you know fashion and she's she's a
designer and she does that all this [ __ ]
so i'm just like you know what
make me your barbie doll do what the
[ __ ] you want it's working yeah she
grabs my clothes and she's like this is
your outfit for the day and i'm like i
would have chosen that that's tight it's
just shorts and a t-shirt
barbell shorts t-shirt yeah but no one
crocodile dundee had no underwear
she chose this
nah but it was in the pile that she left
for me so when she left she she had us a
clothes
called the closet
now i have a box of clothes and then she
has it in order of like so i just pick
it up and i leave when she's on the show
i'm going to play this clip and i'm
going to say did you dress him that day
or not she was [ __ ] out here
[Laughter]
not this i put it together are you
[ __ ] high steve
uh okay here's a question from velen joe
if you could invent something what would
it be
me or the name is joe no no just the
name is valencia oh
oh that's specifically me
hey this question is only for joe nobody
else answered
all right joe go ahead you guys already
said mine like invent something new if
you could invent something what would it
be
and it has to be new
i mean you're like oh i wish i invented
bitcoin or some [ __ ] it's got to be new
okay uh right off the bat i would want
the retractable spork so it's like a
spoon and then you press a button and
then the [ __ ] uh tongs come out in
order for it to be a fork but it's still
spoonable
but why do we care because the spork is
so unthreatening
like a switchblade why did i want to do
it to threaten somebody i just threaten
my soup like
it's like a like a switchblade really no
like a spork no it's not threatening for
your mouth like you like what's the
what's the downslope [ __ ] add the
[ __ ] let me answer the question
what's the down slope on a [ __ ] sport
right now what's what's
oh you keep on stabbing your tongue
anthony your mouth is [ __ ] bleeding
out in your [ __ ] soup
sometimes i want just a full spoon or is
it a cake is it is it camping is it for
camping yeah what's up when you want
sports dude
a setting you can choose where it's a
fork only what the [ __ ] are your
inventions intellectuals you want my
invention yeah what is it but a spork
yeah using d how about using d5 to solve
the student loan crisis oh that's a
brand new concept wow
oh yeah no yeah a lot of people are
talking about using d5 for sure oh sure
hey jennifer lawrence
when i was in fourth grade we had this
as like a assignment and i made a
foldable skateboard so that you can put
in your backpacks when you're like going
around like people can't steal it so
like what i did is i got my skateboard i
cut it in half with a saw and i put like
door locks on it and then you just lock
them and you're able to stand on it and
when you're done you do it and you fold
it put in your backpack so i probably
make that because that's did you patent
it sick no that wasn't fourth
my invention was uh it was the same
thing where you had to make it in school
mine was a freaking uh
like a drum pad where like you know you
just play drums but it was a steering
wheel cover and then it connects to your
radio so you can do drums along with
whatever you're listening to while you
drive
and crash your car while you drive yeah
that's what a great idea yeah
you know people do that [ __ ] oh yeah i
drove a lot all day so i might as well
listen to what you're actually doing
i'll [ __ ] make up a invisible condom
how do you find that was the most joke
how do you find it to put it on
joe's like okay guy community this is
for you don't tell the girls there's no
condom
it's an invisible condom
just invent invisible [ __ ] it just feels
like skin no it's real it you can pre it
protects pregnant look it comes out of
the box hold on a second oh there's no
[ __ ] oh some weight to it sorry
all right oh [ __ ] i dropped it and you
put it up
you gotta get another one hold on uh
it's it's right here
it's so legit it's crazy
and then you open
and then the inside of the box has like
a little bit of of latex caked on the
side so you dip your dick into the
inside of the box real quick and then
you're like look taste it and like oh it
tastes like oh yeah i guess it is an
invisible color
[Music]
you